[Music] It
was in Shichigahama that I started talking about doing men's rhythmic gymnastics in high
school.It was Tsukidate that I had troublesome conversations with the school and the student council after
Bukatsu
was established.  I thought to
myself, I decided to become an ace, so I decided to
go to the inter-high school with everyone and
play an active role as
an ace.  It's
not a super s,
it's an s Don't you
realize it yourself? An absolute presence during acting The
ideal ace I wanted to be
[music]
Then are you giving up
on becoming an ace?  Are you going to give up and stop doing rhythmic gymnastics
?  I'll never quit
Because that's not
what I'm
flying for Then what are you flying for [Music] I wanted to fly too
I want to be like that
Is
that all?
Stand up,
what kind of existence is your ideal ace?